on that day i was the assistant attorney
general in charge of the criminal
division this is before they had
homeland security department and so the
responsibility for dealing with
terrorism fell on the department of
justice and the fbi
and as i was driving into work and i had
my phone on i was talking to my deputy
he said a plane hit the world trade
center
and i thought babe was probably a small
plane pilot who had gotten confused
but as we talked a few minutes later
he said his second plane hit and then we
knew this was an attack
so almost immediately we went over to
the fbi operations center
where
the center of response was going to be
located
as we went over we heard about the plane
hitting the pentagon
and also we learned about the fourth
plane which had been hijacked
and at the fbi we spent that day and
many days afterward
trying to stop more attacks from coming
we
ran down quickly who the hijackers were
by looking at the manifests and relying
on some of the information people phoned
in from the airplanes before they
crashed and we were able to rather
quickly determine that it was probably
bin laden's people at al-qaeda
and then we tracked all the connections
through financial transactions and
communications
to see who else was out there that was
potentially a danger
who why did you think
it was bin laden because of the
connections back in 1993 when the
north tower i think had been
been targeted hadn't it by ramsay
youssef
correct it was 1993 also in the mid 90s
there was actually a plot i think called
inca to blow up airliners in the
philippines that was khalid sheikh
mohammed but as we also looked at the
names on the manifests and we began to
look at how they paid for their
uh tickets and what their communications
network was we were pretty able to trace
it back to people who were known al
qaeda members and so within a matter of
hours we had a strong
connection that we could use to make
further judgments
took less than a month
for the president to take action with
operation enduring freedom what do you
remember about that
well we knew that the attack had come
from uh al qaeda which was based they
were headquartered in afghanistan that
the taliban had refused to turn bin
laden over
and that therefore if we didn't
extract
the taliban from control over
afghanistan and if we didn't chase down
bin laden they would be using it as a
platform for further attacks and so
rather quickly we went in and we
succeeded in dislodging the taliban
and when we arrived and started to push
them back we discovered training camps
and even laboratories where al qaeda was
working on trying to develop
biological and chemical weapons
how long did you expect operation
enduring freedom to last
well i don't know that i had a clear
expectation i think we were very
successful up front initially the
challenge is always what happens after
you win what's the end game and i think
there perhaps we were quite a little bit
flat-footed and not having a clear sense
of the ability to build a cohesive
stable
and peaceful society in the placement of
the tower
and i think a lot of the problems we had
in this
succeeding 20 years were problems
establishing a governance system and a
rule of law in afghanistan
that could really lay down roots
what do you think president bush
would have thought about the decision by
president trump that was then activated
by president biden to pull out of
afghanistan in such a dramatic fashion
to coincide with the anniversary of 9
11.
well i think it was always understood or
expected that at some point the mission
would be concluded
uh i think the deal that the trump
administration struck was not a good
deal for america it was kind of a rushed
deal to find a fig leaf to cover
withdrawal and that's kind of what
president biden was stuck with when he
came into office
i do think though that we could have
done a somewhat better job in staging
our withdrawal even if it meant
reopening the deal or the negotiation
with the taliban but i think at this
point we have the opportunity
to basically say to the taliban
if you want to cooperate with us we can
find some way to be useful uh to your
effort to establish a government but if
you want to go back to the bad old days
we will come down with a lot of force
i spoke to um the former national
security adviser john bolton he was on
my breakfast program last week and he
says that in his opinion
uh the united states is in greater
danger now than it was before 9 11.
would you concur with him
i would not agree with that i mean i
think in terms of dealing with
large-scale terrorist attacks we've
built a very effective infrastructure to
prevent international terrorists from
duplicating a 911
and some of your viewers will remember
august 2006 when we worked with the
british government to disrupt the plot
to blow up a dozen airliners flying out
of heathrow airport to north america so
i think our infrastructure defense is
much better
i do think what's happened is the
internet has given
the extremists more ability to reach
into our own countries and find
sympathetic people who would then be
willing to carry out smaller scale
attacks and that's challenging because
it's not as easily detected as a
large-scale plot
additionally we're now facing domestic
terrorist issues which further create a
multiplicity of challenges for the
security community
okay mr chertoff we must leave it there
but thank you for sharing your expertise
with us today it's very much appreciated
thank you and my condolences to all